뭐 추가 공사비는 그렇다 치더라도
일단 공사가 다 되긴 해야 되잖아요
근데 공사까지도 안 되는 경우가 너무
많습니다
진짜
무슨
[음악]
사람입니다 제가 오늘은
건설사에 대해서 좀 얘기를 해보도록
하겠습니다 최근에 제 주변에 그
공사하고 계신 분 중에 무권 정도가
이제 중간에 하다가 건설사가 부도가
났어요
첫 번째로 묻어났던 거는 부도가 나서
원래 이제 작년 3월 달에 중국
예정이었는데 아직까지도 공사가 안
됐습니다 그동안
금융 비용이라든지
추가 공사비라든지 이런게
정말 손해가 너무 막심하거든요
건설사도 사실 뭐 이곳저곳 그
건축주분은 되게 이곳저곳 비교해서 한
곳이긴 하는데 자세하게 파악을 못하고
계약을 했던 거 같아요 두 번째 업체
같은 경우에는
법률 쪽에 종사하시는 분이었습니다
심지어
계약서나 이런 거 되게 꼼꼼히 보고
했는데 그것도 이제 공사하다가 최근에
이제 부도가 났어요 못하겠다라고 해서
공사하다가
다른 업체가 붙어서 하기가 또 쉽지
않거든요 누가 이제 짓다가 만건대
그래서 나중에 뭐 하자라든지 이런
거에 또 이슈가 있기 때문에
감사하다가
업체가 바뀌면 그거에 대한 리스크는
굉장히 큽니다 그래서
[음악]
우선 건설사를 선정하실 때
지인들 소개를 많이 받아요 주변에
이런 건설업을 하고 있는 사람이
있다라고 해서 소개를 받는 경우가
있는데 일단 여러분들이 뭐 소개를
받거나 할 때도 제일 중요한게 그분이
면허가 있는지를 봐야 돼요
종합건설 면허 실내 인테리어 그런게
아니라 종합건설 면허가 있는지를
확인을 하셔야 됩니다
면허를
빌려서 하는 경우가 되게 많아요 저도
이제 뭐 다른
업체 견적서나 이런 거 보면은 사실
거의 뭐 말도 안 되는 금액입니다
진짜 일단 계약부터 하자라는 그런
견적이 되게 많아요 그래서 나중에
이제 계약하고 나서 부도가 날 수도
있고 아니면 추가 공사비는 당연히
나오고 그래서 면허를 빌려서 하는
경우가 저는 너무 많이 왔습니다
그래서 여러분들이
면허가 있는지 확인하시려면
키스콘이라고 있어요
키스콘이라고 검색하시면 건
산업
지식정보시스템이라고 있습니다 여기
들어가서 여기 이제 검색하는 란에
업체를 검색하시면 돼요 그래서 한번
분산함을 검색해보면 저희가 이제
건설업 등록을
2021년 12월 2일 날
했고요 지금 업태 상태는 정상
처분을 받은 경우에는 요게 좀 다르게
써 있겠죠 그래서 자세하게 보시려면
이거를 클릭하시면 주소가 지금 강남구
청담동 되어 있고 그 다음에
건축공사업이라는 행사 실적은 저희가
한 114억 정도 됩니다 그래서
종합해서 뭐 비주거시설 주거나
비거시설 사무실
빌딩 뭐 이런 거를 이제 봉사할 수
있는
면허가 있구요
종합건설 면허가 있는지 확인을 하셔야
돼요 그리고 여기 밑에 보면 저희가
이제 설립한지는 얼마 안 돼 가지고
뭐 이렇게
데이터가 많지는 않은데 나중에 이제
뭐 과태료라든지 이런게 받은게 있으면
여기서 추가적으로 나옵니다 뭐 재무
정보라든지 나오고요 제가 대부분
시공사 보면은
돌려막기 하는 시공사도 되게 많아요
현장에서 돈 받아서 다른 현장에 또
채우고 그리고 돈 빼가지고 딴 데다
쓰고 이런 경우가 많은데 일단 그
법인이
재무현황 이런 걸 좀 보면 좋을 것
같아요 여기서 뭐 간단하게 보셔도
되고 유료 결제하면은 그 법인의 뭐
이렇게 자금 현황이라든지 이런 거를
좀 간단하게 볼 수 있거든요 이런
최소한의 조회 정도는
하고
계약을 하셔야지 나중에 문제라든지
이런게 좀 발생될 여지가 좀
줄어듭니다
키스콘을 여러분들도 알고 계셨다가
내가 비딩 받은 업체들을 한번 다
검색해 보세요 나랑 얘기했던 사람 그
업체 이름이 맞는지 그 업체가
종합건설 면허가 있는지를
확인하실 필요가 있습니다 그런 경우도
있더라구요 저희가 건설 계약을 하면은
10%를 이제 보증보험을 들어요
그래서 그거는 이제 안전하게 저희가
보상받을 수 있는데 보증보험 발급도
안 해주는데도 있어요
[음악]
문제없이 공사가
추가 공사비는 그렇다 치더라도 일단
공사가 다 되긴 해야 되잖아요 근데
공사까지도 안 되는 경우가 너무
많습니다
진짜
무슨 보통 이제 시시설계를 하고 이제
견적이 나가는게 많은데
허가방에서 그리는 설계 정도로
견적 뭐 평당 얼마 이렇게 해가지고
공사비가 무조건 해놓고 공사하면서
계속 추가비 요구하고 공사는 되지도
않고 갑자기 이제 두 손 두발 다들
경우가 되게 많기 때문에 여러분들
공사 계약할 때 정말 유의하셔야
됩니다
부도나는 회사들이 더 많아질 것
같아요 올해도 그렇고 만약에 공사를
계획 중이시라고 하시면 제가
말씀드렸던 방법들
종합건설 면허가 있는지이 회사가 이런
재무 상태라든지 이런 것들을 그래도
간략하게 파악을 하고 그리고 여기
키스톤 들어가서
뭔가 공사 실적이라든지
뭔가
과태료 받은게 있는지 없는지 막 그런
것도 최소한으로 확인을 하셔 가지고
계약을
진행을 하셔야 됩니다 그래서 오늘
영상 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다